everyone has tattoos oh
i'm gonna be punk rock and not get the
tattoo
it's one thing to commit to a role but
it's a whole other level when it's done
in permanent ink
from commemorative tattoos and memory of
special projects to actors who've gone
full method and gotten inked for their
roles we're diving into the world of
actor tattoos
which knight got a matching tattoo with
other cast members
how about the actor who was responsible
for inking the other actors on set
i actually got a tattoo of a spider no
yeah i did yeah
his foot spidey senses were definitely
tingling when tom holland got this
painfully placed spider-man symbol
tattoo
he got the commemorative chat done in
new york and the actor himself was
surprised he actually did it
he'd always wanted to permanently brand
himself with the power of spider-man but
was never sure he'd actually follow
through with it
that's the date that we both got game of
thrones on yeah
their sisterly bond is forever since
sophie turner and maisie williams
tattooed themselves with the date that
each first began filming for the epic
game of thrones
it is a pretty significant date for both
their careers and their relationship
if you have a hard time spotting
turner's inc it's because she had it
done in peach so it wasn't too
noticeable
a good idea for any actor i can see
nothing absolutely
turner went a step further and also got
a tattoo of a direwolf
the emblem of the stark family on her
forearm how about this little flame
finger tattoo
that's not from game of thrones but in
honor of her role in x-men
i think there are a lot of girls who can
relate to hannah and i'm glad that you
know we're able to execute it the way
that we did
13 reasons why was a hugely impactful
show for so many people
especially selena gomez who forayed into
producing the show
in honor of the production she and two
of the cast members tommy dorfman and
alicia beau got semicolon tattoos in
honor of the series and to raise
awareness of teen mental illness
for dorfman it was quite personal as
he'd struggled with mental health
himself
i mean i think it was just we wanted to
get the tattoo because of the meaning of
the tattoo
so both the tattoo and show meant a lot
for him the ink they all bear is also in
reference to a mental health nonprofit
that the show supported called project
semicolon
i've actually tattooed probably i've
done about almost 50 tattoos now what
are you talking about yeah
no one is really sure why it's
misspelled but
margot robbie and many folks from the
suicide squad branded themselves in
honor of the film with the wild tattoo
spelling of
s-k-w-a-d robbie herself was responsible
for brandishing the team members and
even tattooed herself
while they turned her well for the most
part she did screw up the spelling on
one of them
i was writing a word and i spelt it
wrong
thank goodness he didn't pay her for it
in addition to the hashtag squad tattoos
many members of the team got what is
affectionately called the tomoji
happy faces robbie tattooed on the
bottom of people's toes
she's like let's get a tattoo when we
rap and i thought
that sounds so awesome have you binged
the flight attendant yet
if not now is definitely the time kaylee
cuoco and zosia mamet gives stellar
performances
they loved it so much they even got
matching tattoos alongside other members
of the team to commemorate the
experience
these little paper airplanes leaving a
tiny trail behind on their ankles are an
obvious nod to the title of the show
check out this little bee tattoo does
amelia clark just have an affinity for
little bugs
nope it's actually an odd tour character
lou in the film me before you
who sported the same one there are also
some dainty dragons on her wrist that
she got shortly after wrapping game of
thrones
in memory of her time as daenerys
because you're coming in
to get a tattoo of a dragon yes okay are
you really doing it
this tattoo was done by the same tattoo
artist who did the bee
the famous dr wu this the movie a star
is born it's a love
story we worked so hard this giant rose
tattoo along her spine is gorgeous and
an evident ode to the film star is born
le'veon rose is of course the title of
the edith piaf song she sings in the
movie anyone who watched her performance
live with bradley cooper knows it was a
hugely significant experience for her
it only makes sense she kept its memory
alive with the tattoo just as beautiful
as the movie
scarlett it was your idea for what the
original six avengers
to become tattooed together um yeah yeah
i thought
well i think chris evans and i kind of
came up when scarlett johansson has an
idea
she commits to it the actress decided to
get an avengers tattoo with chris evans
and then she and evans convinced the
other members of the avengers to do the
same
and they were successful in convincing
everyone
except mark ruffalo i'm afraid of
needles
okay so there's that the tattoo artist
who did it for evans and johansson
actually
flew down to la and gave the matching
tattoos with secret images embedded in
them to jeremy renner
robert downey jr and chris hemsworth
that large tattoo of a sparrow flying
over the ocean that's seen on johnny
depp's arm in the first of the pirates
of the caribbean
films while it may be a fake one created
by a makeup artist
he did end up getting an almost exact
replica permanently done in the same
spot
his actual tattoo has the sparrow facing
the opposite way of the one seen in the
film
how about the name jack written
underneath it it seems like it could be
an odd to his character name but
it's actually in honor of his son who
just happens to be called jack
then i was like hey like i really want
to get a tattoo if any of the pretty
little liars actresses raise their index
finger to their mouth to
shh anyone it would be obvious which
show they did
lucy hale shay mitchell sasha peterson
troy and belisario
janelle parrish and ashley benson all
got initials of their characters
tattooed in the same spot on their
fingers to celebrate the long-running
series that played a significant role
in all of their careers you know i don't
know if you have a tattoo but it's sort
of like you get something
for one initial reason and then it turns
into a million different reasons
adults get tattoos all the time but for
the young actors who were part of the
descendants 2 team
the decision was much bigger many of the
members of the team got these anchor
tattoos
though they all brought their own
personal style and preference to them
since they all vary in size and shape
one thing for sure is that they all look
brilliant the epic lord of the rings
films weren't just epic for us
but the whole cast too after rapping
shooting for the fellowship of the rings
in 2001
the nine of the group got the word nine
tattooed in elvish as a way of keeping
them connected to each other for the
rest of their lives
they also chose different locations for
the tattoos and even sir ian mckellen
joined in on the fun and got his tattoo
on his shoulder
it says nine elvish from nine brian
cranston
aka walter white commemorated his time
on breaking bad with a small hidden
tattoo of the show's logo
a riff on the periodic table of elements
on his finger
why that specific hidden spot choice
people would say
wait a minute why would you put it there
no one can see it and i go
i can see it for the actor it was about
keeping the tattoo as a reminder to
himself of the journey he went on with
the show
cranston wasn't the only one to get
inked it's no surprise his sidekick
aaron paul
aka jesse pinkman got a chat as well
much less hidden the phrase
no half measures is placed on the inside
of paul's forearm
aside from being a quote from his
character in the show it was also the
name of the 12th episode in the third
season
why is this significant well it's the
episode that walter fully committed to
being in business with pinkman
walter wasn't looking back and neither
was paul when he got the tattoo
after going through the intense
experience of playing sister wives in
mad max fury road
the actors all got small tattoos of
three little dots in the shape of a
triangle to commemorate the experience
now they will definitely be sister wives
for life in
spirit that is watching shia labeouf in
his more recent films it's hard to tell
which tattoos are real since he's gotten
so many for both personal reasons and
for roles
he got a whopping 12 individual tattoos
for his role in american honey
including two portraits of missy elia
above his kneecaps
if that weren't enough he also got a
huge chest tattoo for his role in the
film the tax collector
talk about going full method after
shooting the first season of a series of
unfortunate events and learning it would
be renewed for his second season
neil patrick hair celebrated by getting
his very first tattoo
then you posted a photo uh that makes it
seem like you maybe got the actual
tattoo
i did and you did the same one that his
character count olaf had on his ankle
must have been a nice break for the
makeup artists who no longer had to
apply the fake one each time he was
shooting
talk about commitment i'm sincerely just
super proud of the show
so many of these tattoos are beautiful
reminders of the pivotal moments in
their careers and lives
we wonder if any other actors will go so
far as to tattoo their
entire chest like shia labeouf would you
go that far for a role